[MUSIC PLAYING]
COHEN: Hello.
Hello.
I'm Josh Cohen.
I teach in the linguistics and
philosophy department here.
And I'm the head of the
Political Science Department.
And I'm up here now because
I'm the chair of the Colloquium
Committee that organized
this two day event.
I'd like to welcome all of you
to this first session of a two
day colloquium entitled,
Asking the Right Questions,
in which we celebrate the
50th anniversary of MIT
School of Humanities,
Arts, and Social Sciences.
Since 1950, the
school has been home
to an extraordinary collection
of scholarly activities,
of composers and economists,
linguists and literary critics,
historians, anthropologists,
philosophers, and many others,
who pursue topics ranging
from the analytical study
of human language, market
exchange and group conflict,
to the interpretive examination
of texts, histories,
and cultures, to the imaginative
exploration of human passions
and relationships.
It's an unusual school and
an unusual institution.
And our hope is that
you'll come away
from these two
days with a deeper
sense of the
contribution to knowledge
that comes from the school.
Not so much preoccupied with
CP Snow about whether there
are two cultures, or three
cultures, or six, or nine,
in the scholarly world,
but instead engaged
by the questions that we're
going to be discussing here.
Before proceeding,
I want to express
thanks to the other
members of the committee
that organized the event,
Colleagues at MIT--
Pete Donaldson, Ross
Williams, Alan Brody,
and Olivier Blanchard.
But I particularly want
to take the opportunity
to thank Phil Khoury, who bears
substantial responsibility
for making this
colloquium come off, bear
substantial responsibility
for everything
that moves around
this side of campus,
and I think more
fundamentally is really
a person, as everyone
who knows him
knows, of extraordinary decency,
a great pleasure to work with.
And I'd like to thank
him on behalf of everyone
at MIT for all that he
does for the institute.
[APPLAUSE]
All that he does
at the institute,
including, if I may say, until
about 11 o'clock this morning
sending me instructions about
what I should be saying now.
But I needed the instructions.
I welcome it.
So this two day
colloquium is one
of four parts of the 50th
anniversary celebration.
A second part is an
exhibition, which
opened last month in MIT's
Compton Gallery in building
10 called, A 50 Year
Reflection on the Humanities,
Arts, and Social
Sciences at MIT.
As I say, it opened last month.
It's going to continue
until the end of January.
But it will be open this
weekend, special hours.
And the Nobel Prize
medals will be on display.
But don't get any bright ideas.
There's an MIT
officer who's going
to be guarding the medals.
Another part of
the four part event
are some concerts
tonight at Kresge,
beginning at the
Kresge oval at 7:15
with a performance
directed by Evan Ziporyn.
And then in Kresge
auditorium at 8:00,
a concert with performances
by the MIT Wind Ensemble,
the Chamber Music Society,
Festival Jazz Ensemble,
symphony orchestra,
and concert choir.
And that concert will
celebrate, among other things,
the arts at MIT and the addition
of the arts to our masthead,
as in School of Humanities,
Arts, and Social Sciences.
And then the final event is
the dinner tomorrow night
at the Boston
Museum of Fine Arts.
Now, as to the
colloquium itself,
beginning about a
year and a half ago,
Phil Khoury organized
a series of discussions
about how we might celebrate
our 50th anniversary.
And a consensus emerged
through those discussions,
that the right way
to do this was not
so much to applaud past efforts,
or celebrate past achievements,
but instead to have an event in
which we do what we do when we
do it well, that is to
think, talk, and argue
about large themes of
real human importance.
Time and world permitting,
everyone in the school
would have a chance to
discuss his or her work.
But Andrew Marvell was
right, both time and world
are in unhappily scarce supply.
So we decided to focus
on four large themes that
have been persistent foci
of attention of humanists,
artists, and social
scientists over the 50 year
life of the school.
So we have four topics, each
defined by a broad question.
And I'll just state
the questions,
say who's going to
be speaking to them,
and leave to the panels
themselves and the chairs
of the panels the
introduction of the themes
in more detail and the
introduction of the speaker.
So this session, what do
we know about human nature?
Will go from,
well, 1:15 to 3:00,
or so, with Noam Chomsky, Steve
Pinker, and Hilary Putnam.
Then, after a short
break, at 3:30,
we start again with a topic, how
do artists tell their stories?
With three artists who tell
stories in different media,
composer John Harbison,
novelist Anita Desai,
and poet Louise Gluck.
Then tomorrow at 9:30,
how do history and memory
shape each other?
With John Dower, Pauline
Mair, and Dame Gillian Beer.
And we finish tomorrow at 1
o'clock with the question,
is capitalism good
for democracy?
With Suzanne Berger, Bob
Solow, and Ken Arrow.
And I want to take this
opportunity to thank all
the participants on
all the sessions,
but particularly Hillary-- was
my teacher in graduate school--
Gillian Beer, Ken
Arrow, and Louise Gluck
for joining us on
this special occasion.
All the sessions, as
you probably know,
will be in this room.
And as you may not know,
for those who come tomorrow,
lunch will be served in the
faculty club between sessions.
And on that mundane
but essential detail,
I'll hand things
over to my friend
Jay Keyser who is the
Peter de Florez Professor
of Linguistics, Emeritus.
And Jay will introduce
our first question.
Jay.
Thank you.
KEYSER: Welcome to the School
of Humanities, Arts, and Social
Sciences version of
The Three Tenors.
I will be your moderator
for this session.
You can tell who I am.
I'm the one with the longest
name on the name tags there.
My name is Samuel Jay Keyser.
So I'll say a word about how
the event will be structured
and then we'll begin.
So what I'll do is
introduce each speaker.
And they'll speak in the
order of Steve Pinker and then
Hilary Putnam and
then Noam Chomsky.
Each speaker will speak
for about 20 minutes,
and then we'll take
questions from all of you.
And as Josh says, we should
go up to about 3 o'clock.
So I thought I
might try to lay out
a kind of a context
for the discussion.
In 1958, as a graduate student
in linguistics at Yale,
I was taught that
the study of language
was the study of finite corpora.
The job of the linguist
was to choose a language,
collect a finite, if large,
corpus of that language
and describe it.
I remember that one of my
old mentors, Bernard Bloch,
used to refer to that
exercise as collecting
your 40 notebooks of Choctaw
and then describing it.
Three years later,
I came to MIT.
Here I learned something
radically different.
"Language is a process of free
creation, and I'm quoting,
its laws and
principles are fixed,
but the manner in which the
principles of generation
are used is free and infinitely
varied," end of quote.
The quotation is
from Noam Chomsky
and the import is that language,
an important, perhaps the most
important aspect
of human nature,
is quintessentially infinite
creativity within a finite set
of boundaries.
Now, this point of view often
glimpsed in the 19th century
by critics such as Wilhelm
von Humboldt, or Samuel Taylor
Coleridge, and
Friedrich von Schlegel,
was elevated to the
level of a science at MIT
in the middle of this century.
Creativity, within
fixed boundaries,
goes beyond Homo sapiens.
It is a reflection of a
fundamental property of life.
Unity, IE, fixed boundaries
within diversity,
IE, creativity, are two
sides of the same coin.
The 450 different
species of birds
that live on the shores
of Lake Baringo in Kenya
are, nonetheless, cut
from the same cloth.
The thousands of varieties
of flowers are, in a sense,
a single flower.
The faces of humankind, as
varied as they seem to be,
are, nonetheless,
variations on a single face.
The thousands of natural
languages in the world
are, at some level,
the same language.
From the perspective
of unity and diversity,
then nothing could be more
natural than language.
From the perspective of
human nature, what is special
is the element of freedom that
accompanies our mental life
as it is mirrored in language.
Well, that'll be
sort of the context.
And I'd like to go immediately
to our first speaker,
and that is Steve Pinker.
By the way, I'm the emeritus
Peter de Florez professor.
Steve is the current
holder of it.
So in a way, I'm a
surrogate father.
Don't stay out late, Steve.
It's a bit frightening
to think that I've
known Noam and Hilary longer
than our first panelist has
been alive.
I guess, that's
the kind of thing
you have to expect when you
celebrate 50 years of anything.
If careers where
music compositions,
Steve's would be
the 1812 Overture
with the fireworks reserved for
his spectacular series of books
aimed at the interested but
uninformed general public.
In 1994, The Language
Instinct, his first book,
was named 1 of the 11
best books of the year
by The New York
Times Book Review
and it won the William James
Book Prize of the American
Psychological Association.
In fact, he's the recipient of
2 William James Book Prizes,
as well as the Los
Angeles Times Book Prize
in Science and Technology.
He was a finalist
for the Pulitzer
Prize in nonfiction in the
National Book Critics Award
Circle--
Circle Award he should have won.
Many have rested on the laurels
of the likes of the language
instinct, not Steve.
He followed that book up with
How The Mind Works in 1997,
and Words and
Rules in 1999, each
a tour de force
in its own right.
And he's currently
working on yet another
to be called The Blank Slate.
Steve is on a roll,
one which I strongly
suspect will go on
for the next 50 years.
Steve Pinker.
[APPLAUSE]
PINKER: Thanks, Jay.
Thank you very much, Jay.
Thank you, Josh.
And thank you, Phil, and
all of you for coming.
The topic of this
afternoon's symposium
is, of course, of
perennial importance,
because everyone has a
theory of human nature.
Everyone has to predict
how other people will
react to their surroundings.
And that means that
we all depend on
theories, explicit or implicit,
on what makes people tick.
Much depends on our
theory of human nature.
It affects everything from how
we manage our relationships
and how we bring
up our children,
to our theories of
education, politics, and law.
For thousands of years, the
dominant theory of human nature
was the Judeo-Christian
tradition,
which had claims on
the subject matter
now covered by
psychology and biology.
For example, it proposed
a modular theory of mind
in which the mind contains
a moral sense which
can recognize standards of good
and evil and uncaused decision
making process and
a capacity for love.
The Judeo-Christian theory
was based on specific events
narrated in the Bible.
For example, the,
we know that people
have the capacity for choice
because Adam and Eve were
punished for eating the fruit of
the tree of knowledge implying
that they could have
chosen otherwise.
With the decline of
literal interpretations
of the truth of biblical events,
the Judeo-Christian theory
of human nature has been
dissolving among intellectuals.
But since a theory of
human nature is necessary,
a new one had to take its place.
I'm going to suggest
that the standard secular
theory of human nature that's
been with us until recently
is composed of three
doctrines, each associated
with a modern philosopher.
I should hasten to
add that I'm going
to be using these philosophers
really as hooks for the ideas.
And it should go without
saying that their actual bodies
of thought are far
more sophisticated
than the sound bites that
I'll present you today.
The first is The Blank
Slate, or tabula rasa,
literally scraped tablet,
often incorrectly attributed
to John Locke.
What he really said
was as follows,
let us suppose then the
mind to be, as we say,
white paper, void of all
characters, without any ideas.
How comes it to be furnished?
When comes it by
that vast store,
which the busy and
boundless fancy of man
has painted on it with an
almost endless variety?
Whence has it all the materials
of reason and knowledge?
To that, I answer in one
word, from experience.
It's easy to see why
The Blank Slate should
have been an appealing
doctrine in Locke's time,
as it is today.
Dogmas, such as the
divine right of kings,
are not self-evident
truths, but have
to be justified by experiences
that minds can share.
If ideas come from experience,
then differences of opinion
come from different experiences,
not from defective minds.
And therefore, at least in the
conventional interpretation
of Locke, it gives us grounds
for tolerating differences
of opinion.
If all of us are blank slates,
this undermines the notion
that the royalty and aristocracy
have some innate advantage
and suitability to
rule, and conversely, it
undermines slavery
by saying that slaves
are not innately
inferior, or subservient.
The Blank Slate has
had an enormous impact
on contemporary
intellectual life.
Psychology for much
of this century
has devoted itself to the
study of the simple mechanisms
of association that
Locke first described.
The social sciences have invoked
culture and socialization
as the primary
explanatory constructs.
I'm going to give
you an example of how
the idea has penetrated into
another famous 20th century
philosopher.
I think of a child's
mind as a blank book.
During the first
years of its life,
much will be written
on the pages.
The quality of that writing
will affect his life profoundly.
Who said that?
Walt Disney.
Now, the second
doctrine was first
introduced in the
following verse
by John Dryden in The
Conquest of Granada.
I am as free as
nature first made
man, ere the base
laws of servitude
began, when wild in woods
the noble savage ran.
The expression the noble
savages incorrectly
attributed to Rousseau,
although he did
write something quite similar.
So many authors have
hastily concluded
that man is naturally
cruel and requires
a regular system of police to be
reclaimed, whereas nothing can
be more gentle than him
in his primitive state
when placed by nature
at an equal distance
from the stupidity of brutes
and the pernicious good sense
of civilized man.
The more we reflect on this
state, the more convinced
we shall be that it was the
least subject of any two
revolutions, the best
for man, and that nothing
could have drawn him out of
it, but some fatal accident,
which for the public good,
should never have happened.
The example of the
savages, most of whom
have been found
in this condition,
seems to confirm that
mankind was formed ever
to remain in it, that
this condition is
the real youth of the
world, and that all ulterior
improvements have been so
many steps in appearance
towards the perfection of
individuals, but, in fact,
towards the decrepitness
of the species.
It's easy to see the appeal
of the doctrine of The Noble
Savage, that we
are innately good
and that our social institutions
cause us to do wrong.
There is no need for the
domineering Leviathan,
that Hobbes, Rousseau's foil
in that passage, proposed.
If we're nasty, our best
hope is an uneasy truce,
whereas if we're
essentially noble,
a happy society is our
birthright, a cheerier thought.
Children, in a sense,
are born savages.
So if the savage in us is
nasty, then child rearing
is an arena of
discipline and conflict,
whereas if the savage
is noble, child rearing
consists of providing
children with opportunities
to develop their potential.
Finally, it'd be nice
to think that evil
is the product of
a corrupt society
rather than a dark side
that's insufficiently tamed.
The Noble Savage,
like The Blank Slate,
has a remarkable degree of
penetration in our unspoken
theory of human nature.
I think it can be seen in
the respect for the natural
and distrust of the man
made that manifests itself
in many arenas, such as the
opposition to genetically
modified food, the unfashioned
ability of authoritarian styles
of child rearing,
and the understanding
of social problems as repairable
defects in our institutions,
something that virtually
all of us share,
as opposed to an
older view that they
are part of the inherent
tragedy of the human condition.
The third doctrine
is commonly linked
with Descartes, the notion
of mind, body dualism.
And again, I will
give you a sound bite
that doesn't do real justice
to his body of thought.
When I consider the
mind, that is to say,
myself in as much as I
am only a thinking being,
I cannot distinguish
in myself any parts,
but apprehend myself to
be clearly one and entire.
The faculties of willing,
feeling, conceiving, et cetera,
cannot be properly speaking
said to be its parts,
for it is one in the same mind,
which employs itself in willing
and in feeling and
in understanding.
But it is quite otherwise with
corporeal, or extended objects,
for as there is not one
of them imaginable by me,
which my mind cannot
easily divide into parts.
This would be
sufficient to teach me
that the mind or soul
of man is entirely
different from the body.
The Ghost in the Machine
is the abusive term
for this doctrine introduced
by Gilbert Ryle 50 years ago.
And it's easy to see
why the notion that we
are suffused with some
non-mechanical spirit
should be appealing.
Machines, such as the
body is composed of,
are insensate, built to
be used and disposable.
Humans are sentient, possessing
of dignity and rights,
and infinitely precious.
Machines have some
workaday purpose,
like grinding corn,
or sharpening pencils.
Humans have a higher purpose,
love, worship, good works,
knowledge, beauty, and so on.
Machines follow the
laws of physics,
behavior is freely chosen.
With choice comes optimism
about our possibilities
for the future and the
ability to hold others
accountable for their actions.
Finally, given the doctrine
of The Ghost in the Machine,
the mind can survive
the death of the body,
an idea whose appeal
should be all too obvious.
Again, I think this
is a doctrine that
pervades our common sense
theories of human nature.
We see it in the fact that
freedom, choice, dignity,
responsibility, and
rights are commonly
seen as incompatible with a
biological view of the mind.
We see it in the common use of
determinism and reductionism
as boo words, as words that
no one ever really explains
what they mean by
them, but everyone
knows that they're bad.
And in everyday
thinking and speech
you often can see speculation
about brain transplants.
In reality, they would
be body transplants,
because as Dan
Dennett pointed out,
the brain transplant
is the one transplant
operation where
it's better to be
the donor than the recipient.
And we see it in
everyday language
as when we refer to
John's body, or even
John's brain, which
presupposes some entity that
owns the brain, and yet is
somehow distinct from it.
I think over the
last 50 years there
have been a number of threats
to each of these doctrines.
And in the rest
of my remarks I'd
like to indicate
what they are and how
we might deal with them.
The foremost, I think, is
the Chomskyan Revolution
in linguistics and
cognitive science,
where Noam in the
1950s first proposed
that, quite contrary to the
doctrine of the blank slate,
every normal child is
fitted with a language
faculty, a language
acquisition device, which
is necessary for the
learning of languages
to take place, no learning
without innate learning
algorithms.
And in the rest of
cognitive science,
there have been
parallel proposals
for learning circuitry,
which must be there in order
for learning to happen.
In developmental psychology,
my colleague Elizabeth Spelke
and others have shown
that infants in the crib
have a remarkable degree of
cognitive and psychological
faculties operating
just about as
soon as their brain
has developed.
In behavioral genetics, the
study of adoptees and twins,
there is evidence that
about half the variation
in intellectual skills
and in personality traits
can be tied to
differences in the genes.
And evolutionary psychology has
documented an astonishing list
of traits that are universal
across the world, 6,000
cultures, just as
Noam has proposed
a universal grammar, the
anthropologist Donald
Brown influenced by
Chomsky has proposed
a universal people, a set of
traits that includes everything
from logical operators in
language to arranging of hair
for aesthetic reasons to sexual
and child rearing practices.
And primatology has shown
that our hairy cousins have
a number of
psychological abilities,
such as a concept of
number and many emotions
and facial expressions,
despite their lacking culture
and socialization processes,
as we see in people.
The Noble Savage, I think,
has also been threatened.
Behavioral genetics has shown
that many of the nasty traits
that we find in people,
such as antagonism,
a lack of conscience, a
tendency towards violent crime,
and psychopathy, are
partly heritable.
Neuroscience has identified
brain mechanisms associated
with aggression, as
well as brain mechanisms
that inhibit it.
And evolutionary
psychology and anthropology
have documented
that conflict is as
universal in the
human species as it
is in the rest of
the natural world.
This is my one graph of data.
It shows the percentage
of male deaths
due to warfare in a variety
of hunter gatherer and hunter
horticultural societies
indicated in red, mostly
in the Amazon and in the
New Guinea highlands.
For comparison, the
blue bar at the bottom
shows the same
statistic percentage
of male deaths due to
warfare in the US and Europe
in the 20th century, including
the statistics of the two world
wars.
So much for Rousseau.
And I think The
Ghost in the Machine
has also come under threat.
Cognitive science is based
on the computational theory
of mind, a theory, I
think, first most clearly
articulated by Hilary Putnam
in a famous 1960 paper.
Although Hilary is now one
of the severest critics
of that original approach.
Nonetheless, I think it's
still the dominant approach
in cognitive
science and it tries
to explain the airy immaterial
processes of thinking
and feeling in terms of
the mechanical notion
of computation, that beliefs
are a kind of information,
thinking is a kind
of computation,
and the emotions are a kind of
feedback and control mechanism.
In neuroscience, also the
ghost has been under assault,
Francis Crick
wrote a book called
The Astonishing Hypothesis,
alluding to the discovery
that all aspects of thinking,
feeling, and perception, as far
as we can tell, can be linked
to the physiological activity
of tissue of the
tissues of the brain.
Now, these threats to the
three secular doctrines
have not been met
with equanimity,
and there have been
hostile reactions
to these developments
of the last 50 years
from both the left
and the right.
From the academic
left, there have
been accusations of racism,
sexism, and Nazism of people,
who are clearly none of those,
for espousing refutations
of the three doctrines.
Just as one nostalgic
example, here's a poster
from the mid 1980s coming
here Edward L. Wilson,
sociobiologist, and the prophet
of right wing patriarchy.
And if you see, the
bottom of the slide
says, bring noisemakers.
Nice touch.
The religious and cultural
right have been just as outraged
with accusations of immorality
and spiritual bankruptcy.
Here's a quote from the
Weekly Standard, which
I think is typical of the
right wing press' reaction
to the new sciences
of human nature.
But evolution,
cognitive science,
and neuroscience are sure
to give you the creeps,
because whether a
behavior is moral,
whether it signifies virtue, is
a judgment that the new science
and materialism in
general cannot make.
In contrast, the
Judeo-Christian view
says that human
beings are persons
from the start endowed
with a soul created
by God and infinitely precious.
This is the common understanding
the new science means to undo.
Why the fear and loathing?
Why these intemperate reactions?
And how might they be addressed
by people who are legitimately
concerned with the human values
they are taking to threaten?
I think the fears can be
reduced to three main ones.
The first is the fear that if
the mind has innate structure,
then different races,
sexes, or individuals could
be biologically different.
Blank is blank.
If we're all blank slates, we
are by definition identical.
If something is
written on the slate,
different things could be
written on different slates,
and that would condone
discrimination and oppression.
The responses to this
are, first of all,
that as the political
scientist James Flynn wrote,
the truth cannot be
racist, or sexist,
that regardless of what the
facts turn out to be on average
differences among
subsets of people,
for those who are interested
in studying that sort of thing,
that does not impact on the
ethical and moral decision
of how we ought to treat people.
And in particular,
discrimination
against individuals on the
basis of certain group averages,
such as an entire
race or sex is simply
indefensible on moral
and political grounds.
A position, by the
way, that I think
was eloquently articulated by
Noam Chomsky in a 1970 article
called Psychology and Ideology.
Second fear is that
if unpleasant traits
are innate, aggression,
xenophobia, sexism, race, rape,
harassment, and so on, that
would make them, first of all,
natural, and therefore, good,
or else be unchangeable.
Their responses to this, that,
first of all, the first part
is a non-sequitur.
Is does not imply ought, as the
philosopher G. E. Moore pointed
out 100 years ago, and
conversely ought does not imply
is.
Even if it would be nice to
think that people are basically
noble savages, the niceness and
pleasantness of that thought
is not enough to make it true.
Also, the human mind is
complex with many parts.
And even if there
were ignoble motives,
it doesn't mean that we're
condemned to ignoble behavior,
because those motives are not
the only contents of the mind.
With a complex multi-part
mind, ignoble motives
can be counteracted by
other motives and thoughts,
such as an innate moral sense,
or a cognitive recognition
of the mutual benefits that
come about through cooperation.
And indeed, only by
understanding our darker side
can we hope to
control it by trying
to pit the more noble motives
against the ignoble ones.
Finally, there's the
fear that if behavior
is caused by a person's biology,
he can't be held responsible
for it.
As in, the excuse, I
can't help it, honey.
I'm just following an
imperative to spread my genes.
I think the response
for that is,
first of all, an ancient
one, that explanation is not
the same as exculpation, or as
the saying goes, to understand
is not to forgive.
It can't be true that
when we understand
what makes people tick,
that we can no longer set up
contingencies of
moral evaluation,
of reward, and praise,
and condemnation
that would, in the future,
affect that kind of behavior.
Also, bogus defenses
for bad behavior
are, in the 20th
century, ironically,
more likely to be
cultural than biological.
We've had the abuse
expuse that was
used to exonerate the Menendez
brothers in their first trial,
the pornography made
me do it defense
used by clever lawyers
of rapists and harassers,
and the black rage syndrome that
William Kunstler was prepared
to use to defend Colin Ferguson,
the Long Island Railroad
gunman.
But my favorite
example is the song
by the Jets in West Side Story
that I'm sure you all remember.
According to the
Sondheim lyrics,
the Jets sang, dear,
kindly, Sergeant Krupke, you
gotta understand, it's
just our bringing up-ke
that gets us out of hand.
Our mothers all are junkies,
our fathers all are drunks.
Golly Moses,
natcherly we're punks.
So in conclusion, I think
the religious theory
of human nature was replaced
within 100 years ago
and more by the doctrines
of The Blank Slate,
The Noble Savage, and
The Ghost in the Machine.
This theory is being challenged
by the cognitive revolution
and the revolutions in
neuroscience, genetics,
and evolution.
It's seen as a threat
to deeply held values.
But I would argue
that that threat
is more apparent than real.
On the contrary, I think
the taking human nature
into account can help
us clarify these values.
Specifically, it's a bad idea
to say that discrimination
is wrong just because the traits
of all humans are identical.
It's a bad idea to say
that war, violence, rape,
and greed are wrong
because humans are not
naturally inclined to them.
And it's a bad idea
to say that people
are responsible
for their actions
just because the causes of
those actions are mysterious.
They're bad ideas
because they imply,
either that scholars
must be prepared
to fudge their data for
a higher moral purpose,
or we must all be prepared
to relinquish our values.
And I would argue that
that is one choice that I
hope we don't have to make.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
KEYSER: That was great, Steve.
PINKER: Thanks, Jay.
KEYSER: Our next speaker
is Hilary Putnam.
I first met Hilary when
I came to MIT in 1961.
It was his first of five
years on the MIT faculty
before moving on to Harvard,
where he's been ever since.
In a review of
Hilary's recent book,
The Threefold Cord,
Mind, Body, and World,
his fellow philosopher
Simon Blackburn says,
quote, "Hilary Putnam is one of
the most distinguished living
philosophers whose brilliant
and fertile writings now
span half a century.
His range is enormous.
It is difficult to think
of an aspect of philosophy
that he has not touched,
from formal logic
to the philosophy of religion,
from quantum theory to ethics.
He has been constantly
at the center
of debates in the philosophy
of mind and language,
where positions that he
was the first to articulate
have become landmarks
in the field."
End quote.
A colleague of mine
recently told me
that when the list of great
philosophers of the last 50
years is compiled, Hilary
Putnam will be among them.
We are fortunate
to have him here
to help us celebrate 50
years of humanities at MIT.
Hilary Putnam.
[APPLAUSE]
PUTNAM: I'm going
to put these here.
Compared to Steve
Pinker, my range tonight
will not be enormous.
In the Encyclopedia
of Philosophy,
the article titled
Godel's Theorem
begins with a terse statement.
Why is it doing that?
This is a disaster.
Any idea?
Something about the slide.
I don't know.
Well, this unreadable--
this opaque transparency.
I think the lady who made it
didn't know how to make them.
Begins with a following
terse statement.
Those of you who knew him may--
in the interest know it was
written by Jonathan
[? Huyenard. ?] By
Godel's Theorem, the following
statement is generally meant,
in any formal system
adequate for number theory--
no-- we just had it.
Well, it's a dark subject.
In any formal system--
and this is the
first time I haven't
made my own transparencies.
From now on I go back
to making my own.
There exists an
undesirable formula.
There is a formula
that is not provable,
and whose negation
is not provable.
This statement is
occasionally referred to
as Godel's first theorem.
A corollary to the theorem
is that the consistency
of a formal system adequate for
number theory cannot be proved
within the system.
Sometime it is this
corollary that is
referred to as Godel's theorem.
It is also referred to as
Godel's second theorem.
These statements
are somewhat vaguely
formulated generalizations
of results published in 1931
by Kurt Godel then in Vienna.
In spite of the
forbidding technicality
of Godel's original
paper, the Godel theorem
has never stopped generating
enormous interest.
Much of that interest
is aroused by the fact
that with the proof
of the Godel theorem,
the human mind
succeeded in proving
that there was something
it could not prove,
or at least not in any
fixed consistent system
with any fixed
finite set of axioms
and with the usual
logic as the instrument
with which deductions are to
be made from those axioms.
In fact, the theorem is
much stronger than this.
Even if we allow the
system in question
to contain an infinite
list of axioms
and to have an infinite list of
additional rules of inference,
the theorem still applies.
Provided, the two
lists can be generated
by a computer, which is allowed
to go on running forever.
Moreover, instead of
speaking a formal systems
adequate for number theory, or
adequate for at least number
theory, one can
speak of computers.
Such version was first
stated by Alan Turing.
The theorem says that
if a computer is allowed
to write down formulas
of number theory
forever, subject
to the constraints
that, one, any deductive
consequence of finite
be many of the formulas in
the list that it writes down
will also get written down
in the list sooner or later,
and, two, the list
is not inconsistent,
that is it doesn't contain
some formula and the negation
of that same formula,
then there is a formula,
in fact, the formula that says
that the list is consistent
is an example, that
is not included
in the list of formulas
generated by the computer.
If we speak of the formulas
listed by the computer
as proved by the computer, and
of a computer of the kind just
mentioned as a
consistent computer,
we can say this
succinctly as follows.
Yeah, this will be another one.
No, no.
This is the wrong--
oh, I guess I did--
did I?
Oh, yes, it was at the
bottom of the page.
Yes, the bottom
of the same page.
That's right.
There is a procedure by which,
given any consistent computer,
a human mathematician can write
down a formula of number theory
that the computer cannot prove.
Of course, those who draw
remarkable conclusions from
this don't mention you could
also say there's a procedure
by which, given any
consistent computer,
a computer can write down a
formula of number theory that
the computer cannot prove.
In 1961, the Oxford philosopher
John Lucas claimed that
the Godel's theorem shows that
non-computational processes,
processes that cannot in
principle be carried out
by a digital computer, even if
its memory space is unlimited,
go on in our minds.
He concluded that our minds
cannot be identical with
our brains, or with
any material system,
since assuming standard physics,
the latter cannot carry out
non-computational processes.
Actually, that's not
actually known, by the way,
but I won't jump up
and down on that.
And hence, that our
minds are immaterial.
More recently, Roger Penrose
used a similar but more
elaborate argument
to claim that we
need to make fundamental
changes in the way we
view both the mind and
the physical world.
Penrose, too, claims
that the Godel's theorem
shows that non-computational
processes must go on
in the human mind.
But instead of positing an
immaterial soul for them
to go on in, he concludes
that these non-computational
processes must be
physical processes.
Physical processes in the
brain, and our physics
must change to account for them.
I was early called upon to
review Penrose's argument.
And my review was
later republished
in the American Math Society.
And like the others
who studied it,
I found many unfillable gaps.
But relax, I'm not
going to ask you
to listen to the details
of Penrose's argument,
nor to a listing of the
places at which it goes wrong.
That's something you can
find in the literature,
if you are interested.
The fact is that
Penrose himself seems
to recognize that there
are gaps in his argument,
even though at the beginning
he promises, I quote,
"clear and simple
proof," unquotes.
And in the end,
he offers a series
of arguments, which
are not mathematical
at all but philosophical.
The philosophical arguments
that Penrose throws in
to plug the gap in his
mathematical reasoning
are numerous.
And they're not sharply set out,
but the heart of his reasoning
seems to go as follows.
Let us suppose that the
brain of an ideally competent
mathematician can be represented
by a consistent computer,
or a consistent computer
program, a program which
generates all and only
correct and convincing proofs.
The statement that the
program is consistent
is not one that the program
generates by Godel's theorem.
So if an ideal
human mathematician
could prove that statement,
we would have a contradiction.
This part of Penrose's reasoning
is uncontroversial correct.
It is possible, however,
that the program--
remember, this
program is supposed
to reproduce the competence of
an ideal human mathematician.
It's possible, however,
that this supposed program
is too long to be consciously
apprehended at all, as long
as the Boston telephone book,
or even orders of magnitude
longer.
In that case, Penrose
asks, how could evolution
have produced such a program?
It would have to
have evolved in parts
and there would be no
evolutionary advantage
to the parts.
But the objection that it's hard
to see how such a thing could
evolve in parts is a
standard objection to all,
or just about all
evolutionary explanations.
One, that it has proved possible
to overcome in case after case,
so though the details
cannot, of course,
be predicted in advance.
First of all, evolution
had better not endow
intelligent beings who are to
have any chance of survival
with reasoning patterns
that lead to contradictions
in daily practice.
If we were always falling
into contradiction
in our everyday
reasoning, we would
be so confused we would not
be around long enough to pass
on our genes.
Of course, there are parts
of mathematics in which
contradictions have arisen.
For example, in Cantor's
theory of transfinite numbers.
It was at first possible to
prove both that there was
and that there was not a
greatest transfinite ordinal.
What mathematicians did was
to add to Cantor's theory
certain, more or less,
ad hoc restrictions,
such as Russell's
theory of types
to get rid of the paradox,
or to get rid of it
as far as we know.
In short, everyday mathematical
reasoning is consistent.
It wouldn't have
arisen if it wasn't.
And when [? Rishashay ?]
mathematics
turns out to contain
contradictions,
we simply troubleshoot it.
In fact, even before
Cantor, we had
to troubleshoot the definitions
of continuity, limits,
et cetera, in the calculus.
The consistency of
mathematics to the extent
that it is consistent
is not such a miracle.
I think I know Penrose's
response to this argument.
In fact, he has a
website in which
he gives responses to my
criticisms and those of others.
He will say I believe that
evolution might explain
why we evolved a program
which is consistent,
at least in its
elementary parts,
such as the theory
of whole numbers,
but that we evolved a style of
reasoning, which is correct,
that is which corresponds
to the platonic truth
about the numbers,
would be a miracle.
The alternative, he suggests, is
that instead of a huge program,
which miraculously corresponds
to the platonic truth
about the numbers, we have
something quite different,
a purely physical
capacity to perform
non-recursive operations
in our brains.
Of course, this
argument of Penrose
is one to appeal
only to those who
are willing to accept his
odd combination of views,
a Platonist view of
mathematics, and a purely
materialist view of the brain.
What his argument
ignores is the fact
that the correct interpretation
of our mathematical concepts
depends on the use
we make of them.
Evolution might indeed
have programmed us
with a different formal
system, but to imagine
that we had been endowed by
evolution with a radically
different system is
the same as imagining
that we had been endowed
with a disposition
to develop different concepts.
It's not as if the
meanings of our words
were fixed prior to
what we do with them,
and evolution had the
task of endowing us
with a program for using words
with those antecedently-fixed
meanings.
Evolution just has
to enable us, it just
has to give us a program
which will enable
us to succeed in our lives.
If we do, then our
mathematical concepts
will admit of some
interpretation, under which
what we say is right.
In fact, that follows from
another theorem of Godel,
the so-called Godel's
completeness theorem.
To see what we can learn
about the human mind,
or at least about how we
should or rather shouldn't
think about the human mind
from the Godel theorem,
I need to point out two
objections that must be raised
against the very question
that Penrose asks,
the question whether
the set of theorems
that an ideal
mathematician can prove
could be generated
by a computer.
I don't have a slide
to go with this.
The first objection, and this
is a point I want to emphasize,
is that the notion of
simulating the performance
of a mathematician
is highly unclear,
or perhaps, I should
say, highly ambiguous.
Perhaps, the
question whether it's
possible to build a
machine that behaves
as a typical human
mathematician behaves
is a meaningful
empirical question.
Say, can you build a machine
which passes a Turing
test for being a mathematician?
But a typical human
mathematician makes mistakes.
The output of an
actual mathematician
contains inconsistencies,
especially
if we are to imagine that
she goes on proving theorems
forever, as the application
of the Godel theorem requires.
So the question of proving
the whole of this output
is consistent does
not even arise.
To this, Penrose replies in the
Shadows of the Mind, his book
Shadows of the Mind, that the
mathematician may make errors,
but she corrects
them upon reflection.
This is true, but to simulate
mathematicians who sometimes
change their minds about
what they've proved,
we would need a
program, which is also
allowed to change its mind.
There are such programs,
but Godel's theorem
does not apply to them.
Trial and error machines,
they are called.
The second objection is that
to confuse these questions,
the question of what an
actual mathematician can do,
and the question of what
an ideal mathematician who
lives forever can do, is to
miss the normativity, the value
laden character of the
notion of ideal mathematics.
The description of
normatively ideal practice
in mathematics,
or any other area,
is not a problem for physics.
It's not my aim
to criticize those
who make the mistake of
thinking that the Godel theorem,
or merely to criticize those
who make the mistake of thinking
that the Godel theorem proves
that the human mind or brain
can carry out
non-computational processes,
that Lucas and Penrose
have made a serious blunder
in their claims about what the
Godel theorem, quote, "shows
about the human mind,"
unquote, is after all widely
recognized, at least in
the logical community.
At the same time,
however, a view
which may seem just
at the opposite end
of the philosophical spectrum
from the Lucas, Penrose view
seems to me to be vulnerable
to the objections I just made.
I refer to the widespread use
of the argument in philosophy
as well as in cognitive science
that whenever human beings
are able to recognize--
here I've put this slide--
I think she printed
this out on a notebook
insert, or something, instead
of transparency paper.
I refer to the--
why can't we see it at all.
Well, maybe when I read it.
I refer to the widespread
use of the following
principle in
philosophy as well as
in cognitive science,
whenever human beings are
able to recognize that
a property applies
to a sentence in a,
quote, "potentially
infinite," unquote,
IE, a fantastically
large set of cases,
then there must
be an algorithm in their
brains that accounts for this,
and the task of
cognitive science
must be to describe
that algorithm.
The case of mathematics shows
that that cannot be a universal
truth.
And my criticism of
Penrose can enable
us to see why we shouldn't
draw any mystical conclusions
about either the mind or
the brain from the fact
that it isn't a universal truth.
But first, a terribly
important qualification,
especially given who my
fellow symposiists are.
And Noam and I were
undergraduates in the program
in linguistics at the
University of Pennsylvania
together as far back as 1944.
I have no doubt that human
beings have the ability
to employ recursions,
another name for algorithms,
both consciously
and unconsciously,
and that there are
recognition out abilities
that cognitive science should
explain, and in many cases,
does explain by appealing to
the notion of an algorithm.
The magnificent contribution
of Noam Chomsky,
in particular, shows
our ability to recognize
the property of grammaticality
is explainable in this way.
Why then do I say that the case
of mathematics shows that it
cannot be a universal truth,
that whenever human beings are
able to recognize that a
property applies to a sentence
in a potentially infinite, that
is a fantastically large set
of cases, there must be an
algorithm in their brains that
accounts for it?
Not quite ready for this.
Well, just as it is true that
we can recognize grammaticality
in a fantastically
large set of cases,
it is true that we can recognize
being proved in a fantastically
large set of cases.
And the Godel theorem does
show, although, by the way,
this requires a different
argument from Penrose,
that if there is an algorithm
that accounts for this ability,
we're not going to be able
to verify that there is.
That is the Godel theorem does
not show that our cognitive
competence cannot be totally
represented by a program,
but it does show, at least
if you extend the argument,
and include not just on
deductive competence,
but our inductive competence,
that if there is a program that
simulates our ideal rationality,
then it would be beyond even
our ideal rationality to
recognize the program that does
it is having that property.
But I think it would be wrong--
and this is a
conclusion I point out
in a paper called Reflexive
Reflection some years ago.
But I think it's wrong to just
stop with that conclusion.
It's wrong because talk about
a potentially infinite set
of cases only makes sense when
there's an algorithm that we
can verify.
Why do I say this?
Well, think for a minute
about the mathematician
that Penrose imagines
he is talking about.
If the mathematician
could really
recognize the potential
infinity of theorems,
then she would be able
to recognize theorems
of arbitrary finite lengths.
That's what it means
to be able to recognize
a potential infinity
of theorems.
For example, theorems to be
too long to be written down
before all the stars are
cooled down, or sucked
into black holes, or whatever.
But any adequate physics of
the human brain, even the one
proposed by Penrose, if
it turns out to be right,
will certainly entail that
the brain will disintegrate
long before it
gets through trying
to prove any such theorem.
In real actual fact, the set of
theorems, a physically possible
human mathematician
can prove is finite.
Moreover, it's not really a set.
This is why I think
my little theorem
about the unrecognized ability
of any algorithm that totally
reproduced ideal human
competence, so it doesn't
engage the real issues,
because it grants that there
is such a thing as the set.
I don't think there's-- it's
not a set, because sets,
by definition, are too valued,
an item's either in or out.
But the predicate
prove is vague.
We can, of course, make
it precise by specifying
a fixed list of axioms
and rules to be used.
And that was why, in fact,
axiomatic mathematics
was developed in
the 19th century,
to make the notion of a proof
more precise, but at a cost.
The Godel theorem
shows that when
you make the notion of
approved precise in that way
by fixing the axioms and
rules to be used, then
there's a perfectly
natural sense in which we
can prove a statement which is
not drivable from those axioms
by those rules.
In other words,
you didn't capture
the whole of the notion of
informal mathematical proof.
Now, you might be driven to
say, OK, by proof, I mean,
or by prove, we mean
prove by any means we
can see to be correct.
But this uses the
essentially vague notion,
see to be correct.
In short, there isn't a
potentially infinite set
of theorems a
mathematician can prove
concerning which we can ask, is
it recursive, or non-recursive?
What there is a vague finite
collection of theorems
that a real flesh and blood
mathematician can prove.
And vague finite collections
are neither recursive nor
non-recursive.
Those concepts only apply
to well-defined sets.
Awful.
But it may be objected.
Didn't Chomsky teach us
that we can and should
idealize language
users by imagining
that, like ideal computers,
they can go on generating
grammatical sentences forever,
sentences of arbitrary length?
Yes, he did.
But the idealization he
showed us how to make
is only precise
because it corresponds
to a well-defined algorithm.
If we take the question, what
can an ideal mathematician
prove to be a precise one?
We must specify just how
the mathematicians all too
finite brain is to be
idealized, just as Chomsky did.
And if we do it by specifying
an algorithm, then, of course,
the result will
be computational.
If this is right, then we should
not allow ourselves to say,
the set of statements that
a mathematician can prove
is a potentially infinite set.
We should only say that
there are fantastically
many statements a mathematician,
an actual mathematician
can prove, at least in
this informal sense,
and let it go with that.
It does not follow
from that fact
that there's an algorithm
such that everything
an ideally competent
mathematician would, or should
one say, should?
Count as proving a
mathematical statement,
is an instance of
that algorithm.
Let's see.
Do I have one more?
Maybe so.
Yeah, I guess that's it.
Yeah, I don't have.
It doesn't follow.
As I say, that there is an
algorithm such that everything
an ideally competent
mathematician would count,
or should, count as proving
a mathematical statement is
an instance of that algorithm,
any more than it follows
from the fact that there
are fantastically many
jokes that a person with
a good sense of humor
can see to be funny.
That there's an algorithm,
such that everything
a person with an ideal sense
of humor would see to be funny
is an instance of
that algorithm.
There is a moral
here for all who
are interested in
cognitive science.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
KEYSER: When I came
to MIT 39 years ago,
I had been invited
to join a project
under the auspices of Morris
Halle and Noam Chomsky.
Morris was at the Center
for Advanced Study
in the Behavioral Sciences
at Palo Alto when I came.
So Noam was the first
person I met at MIT.
I took him to be
typical of the place,
and so I thought I'd come.
At the time, there
was what Tom Kuhn
would have called a paradigm
shift in linguistics.
The scholars under
whom I had studied
did things one way and
Noam did it another.
The discussions were unusually
heated and not without cause.
If Noam was right, then
much of the work being
done in the field
was not just wrong,
which in science is no crime,
but worse, it was useless.
I remember walking along
Vassar Street with Noam
to a coffee shop on Mass Avenue
where the student center now
sits.
I regret that many
people in this audience
can't have that
memory in their heads.
It was a wonderful
shopfront there
and there was a coffee house,
like the Balt in Princeton,
and we used to go there
and it was a great place.
I think WBUR had
radio station there.
And it all changed
when there was a fire.
Anyway, I was walking with
Noam to that coffee shop,
and I asked him what his opinion
of the linguistic wars was.
He said, graduate students
have no vested interest.
They will follow the most
interesting questions.
He was right, they did,
and I was one of them.
Later, Noam told me that, in his
opinion, success in linguistics
was not a question of talent,
but rather of character,
something which undoubtedly
explains the differences
in our two careers.
In 1974, I had the pleasure of
introducing Noam at the Summer
Institute of Linguistics at
the University of Massachusetts
at Amherst.
Since everyone knew who he
was, I thought rather than read
bits and pieces
from his biography,
I would read his horoscope.
25 years later, for
the same reason,
I have the pleasure of
reading his horoscope again.
Shake off lethargy, put
aside preconceived notions,
emphasize the new, be
bold, in your presentation.
Noam Chomsky.
[APPLAUSE]
CHOMSKY: Well, I won't
try to react to that.
I do, however, have one
advantage over Hilary.
I'm not going to
have any problems
with my transparencies,
because I've
managed to get through 50
years without having had any.
And I have one
advantage over Steve,
and namely I'm not
even going to try
to answer the question that was
posed, which makes life easier.
Conclusions about
human nature are
likely to have large
scale human consequences,
and therefore, they have to be
advanced with scrupulous care
and with a recognition of
how little is understood
when we pass beyond
fairly simple systems.
That's true elsewhere in
the organic world as well.
I don't feel that the question
that's raised for discussion
can be answered
with much confidence
in the areas that are
of greatest concern
and significance for
humans, at least not by me.
So I'm going to keep to a
few words about the questions
rather than the answers, and
how they've been conceived,
and the kinds of
problems they raise
when we do try to address them.
Well, at a very general
level, the question
falls within a familiar pattern
of inquiry in general biology.
We're interested in
determining what's sometimes
called the norms
of reaction, that
is the mapping of an environment
into a phenotype, which
corresponds to a
genetic constitution,
particular genetic constitution.
I happen to be paraphrasing
a well-known evolutionary
biologist, but the
point is familiar.
And we can understand
human nature
to be the norms of reaction of
the species abstracting away
from variation, which
is probably fair enough
in the general study of
humans since variability seems
to be fairly small, certainly
relative to our understanding,
but even relative to
closely related species.
The particularly
informative in this quest
is a phenomenon that's
been called canalization
by biologist C. H.
Waddington some years ago.
That's a process whereby
the end state of development
is relatively independent of
environmental perturbations,
so therefore,
heavily constrained
by the genetic endowment
and particularly informative
about it.
These ideas are actually
reminiscent, closely
reminiscent, I think, of
traditional rationalist
conceptions of the origin and
nature of mental faculties.
These efforts,
17th, 18th century,
also concentrated on
what appeared to be fixed
and highly structured
outcomes that
were thought to vary little
with experience, probably
incorrectly, called
common notions
since the early 17th century.
This whole perspective
became influential
in general human
psychology in the 1950s,
in part that was under
the influence of ethology,
comparative zoology.
At first, there was a good
deal of debate over the way
the proposals were formulated.
Konrad Lorenz, who was
particularly influential,
insisted that specific
behaviors were innate,
by which he meant that the
actual behavioral outcome is
genetically determined.
And as was quickly pointed
out, that no one expects--
no biological trade
is expected to be
a product of the
genetic endowment alone,
or trivially a product
of the environment alone.
The outcome is expected to be
some complicated interaction,
interplay of genetic
constitution,
and the environment, of
course, of the environment
with developmental
interactions and processes
that remain rather
poorly understood.
To discover the
genetic constitution,
these various factors have
to be disentangled somehow.
And it's valuable to
apply the approach,
the traditional rationalist
approach, the canalization
approach, and to
take a close look
at possible ranges of outcomes.
The more highly structured
and restricted they are,
the more richly
articulated and canalized,
the more we're likely be
able to find something out
about the organism.
Well, the logic of
the situation dictates
that the endowment
that determines
what the organism can become,
the scope of possibilities
also determines the
limitations of development.
So, for example,
the same endowment
that makes it possible
for a certain embryo
to become a mouse is
going to prevent it
from becoming a bird.
And we should expect
the same to be true
when we approach higher mental
faculties across the board,
in fact.
So for example, it
ought to be true
when we consider the largely
unknown capacities that
enable humans to acquire
deep understanding
in certain domains of inquiry.
And by the same
token, prevent this
in some other, least
possible domains of inquiry,
which might be actual, and
which might even be important,
and which might,
for example, include
the study of human nature.
The human nature
raises questions
that we may not have
intelligence enough to answer.
Descartes speculated,
maybe rightly,
and maybe it's not a matter
of enough intelligence.
Now we look at it differently,
but the wrong kind
of intelligence.
Not an option for Descartes.
Such an intrinsic
structure of intelligence,
which has to be there, should
not occasion regret the--
throughout the biological
world, the limitations
that follow from the very
same endowment that makes
possible rich--
and states rich outcomes.
So it should be an
occasion for celebration.
But there are things we can't
do, even if some of them
turn out to be things
we might like to do.
Well, that's been the framework
for the study of language
for about the last half century.
The norms of
reaction, or sometimes
called a language acquisition
device, what Steve called
the language instinct, the
human genetic endowment, that
determines a specific
language given
particular course of experience,
and by the same token,
prevents other
language like systems
from developing in the mind.
About these aspects of human
nature, a fair amount is known,
at least, more or
less, understood,
but I'm not going
to talk about that.
In principle, it ought to
be possible to approach
other higher mental
faculties in the same way.
In practice, the difficulties
mount very quickly.
Language appears to
be relatively isolated
from other cognitive capacities.
I'm referring here to its
structure, not its use,
and not to components of
the structure, which may
be shared all over the place.
When you turn to other
aspects of mind, for example,
or moral nature,
it's much harder
to isolate components
for separate study,
abstracting them from reflective
thought and many other factors.
Now, nonetheless,
the topics have been
investigated in various ways.
There have been illuminating
thought experiments.
There's been some experimental
work with children.
There's comparative
studies of cross-cultural
and even extending
to other species.
Not uncommonly, the real world
offers occasions, instances,
illustrations of how
the faculties function.
Often, these are
painful choices.
And probably, saw a
couple of weeks ago that
in England British judges and
along with moral philosophers
and the church and
many others were
agonizing over the
question of whether it's
legitimate to murder a child,
one of two Siamese twins,
in order that the other might
have a chance to survive.
Questions like these
test our moral faculties,
a hard test in this case,
maybe impossible one.
And pursuing them may enable
us to discover something
about their nature.
That's the kind of
thought experiment
that has been quite
interestingly pursued.
Sometimes this
perspective, this generally
ecological perspective,
if you like,
is counter-opposed
to another one,
it's called a relativistic
one, which in an extreme form
holds that, apart from the basic
physical structure of a person,
humans have no nature.
They only have history.
Their thought and their
behavior can be modified
at will and without limit.
Actually, nothing like
that can be literally true,
but such views are rather
widely articulated in some form.
In a version that's due
to Richard Rorty, he
whom I'm quoting
now, "humans have
extraordinary malleability.
We are coming to
think of ourselves
as the flexible protean
self-shaping animal,
rather than as having
specific instincts.
Therefore, there can be no
moral progress in human affairs.
Just different ways
of looking at things.
We should put aside
the vain effort
at exploration of
our moral nature,
or reasoned argument about it.
We should keep, to what he
calls, manipulating sentiment,
if we happen to be for or
against torture, or massacre,
or whatever."
I'm probably misinterpreting.
I can't imagine that the words
mean what they seem to say,
but at least that's what
they seem to me to say.
These proposals have,
maybe not surprisingly,
evoked a good deal of criticism.
One recent paper in the
philosophical foundations
of human rights, discussing
Rorty and others,
suggest, and quoting
again, "that nobody
would have taken a
Nazi seriously who
had claimed in 1945
that the sole basis
for moral condemnation
of the Holocaust
is just culturally relative
emotional manipulation based
on shrewdly devised
sentimental stories."
Well, if that's so, and I assume
it is so, we want to know why.
Why is that so?
And if nobody, the
word nobody includes
all normal human
beings, well, we're
back to the question,
the hard question
of intrinsic human nature,
back to the question, but not
an answer.
This notion of unique
human malleability,
contrary to what Rorty
suggests, is not at all novel.
It's quite conventional.
It goes at least
back to the man,
beasts, machine
controversies that
were inspired by Descartes.
Here's one typical
example, argument, in 1740
by James Harris,
English philosopher,
saying that, unlike
animals and machines,
the leading principle
of man is multi-form,
originally uninstructed,
pliant, and docile.
Weakness of instinct
leads to vast variety,
but also to extreme
malleability.
That's an idea that has a
long and quite inglorious
history since that time.
Well, with no metric,
no way of measuring
what how variable
humans are as compared
with others and with very
little understanding,
it's pretty hard to make
any sense of such judgments.
But whatever merit
they have, they
don't seem to seriously offer
an alternative to the approach
that I outlined before this
roughly ethological approach.
We can take for granted,
it's undoubtedly true,
that a person's understanding
and judgment, and values,
and goals reflect the
acquired culture, norms,
and conventions.
But how are these acquired?
They are not acquired
by taking a pill.
They are constructed by the
mind somehow on the basis
of scattered experience,
which they are constantly
applied in circumstances that
are novel and complicated.
These are important facts.
They were discussed
about the same time
as James Harris more than 250
years ago and by David Hume.
He pointed out that the number
of our duties is in a manner
infinite, and therefore, just
as in other parts of the study
of nature, we should try
to-- we should seek--
I'm quoting now-- "general
principles upon which
all of our notions of
morals are founded,
principles that are original
instincts of the human mind,
enhanced by reflection,
but steadfast and immutable
as components of
fixed human nature."
If we don't do that, it's hard
to see how we can make sense
out of the fact that our
duties are commonly new,
we understand them,
we respond to them
in complicated and
novel circumstances.
Well, like Adam Smith,
Hume took sympathy to be,
as he called it, a very powerful
principle in human nature
and the grounding of much else.
That idea was reconstructed
in a Darwinian framework
about 100 years ago by the
anarchist, natural historian,
and zoologist Peter
Kropotkin, what
you might call the founding
volume of the sociobiology,
or evolutionary psychology.
There is recent
work which suggests
some possible evolutionary
scenarios that might
have led to this development.
There's a review of
current work on the topic
in a recent book edited by
Leonard Katz of the philosophy
department here.
To this picture, we should
add some other conceptions
that have been very fruitfully
studied experimentally
in the past several decades.
And I think can reasonably also
be traced back to 17th century
origins of modern science,
including the brain
and cognitive sciences.
One strand of this
is the recognition
that innate capacities
are only latent.
They have to be triggered by
experience to be manifested.
To borrow Descartes analogy,
innate ideas, he said,
are like a susceptibility
to a disease.
The susceptibility's innate,
but you don't get the disease
unless something happens.
That's what he meant
by innate ideas.
Another fruitful idea that
was well examined extensively
in the 17th century is that
the phenomena of the world
don't actually
constitute experience,
rather they become experience,
as our modes of cognition
construct them in specific
ways, and therefore, they
must conform to those
modes of cognition.
These modes of cognition
are a distinctive property
of our nature.
They differ for
different organisms.
They're what Lawrence,
back in the 1930s,
called a kind of biological
a priori differing
for different organisms.
And that's also true of
the experience that's
the basis for the rich
mental constructions
that we call cultures,
or norms, or conventions.
The process of
mental construction
of experience and
interpretation of it
based on a fairly common
genetic constitution,
well, it must be
rich to the extent
that the structures, the
outcomes are highly structured
and constrained and relatively
invariant, canalized,
if you like.
And that appears
to be invariably
the case when, at least,
anything we understand.
And if that's so, then
the relativist approach
is going to turn out to
be profoundly innatist,
at least if it is to address
the kinds of questions that
are studied elsewhere,
the issues of acquisition
and nature and use
of attained systems,
as, say, in the study
of the visual system,
or linguistic systems, or
other products of organisms.
Actually, I doubt
that there really
are conflicts of principle
separating these apparently
contrasting views,
rather emphasis on one
or another aspect of what
an individual person is,
and, of course, empirical
questions, a vast number
and few answers about irrelevant
aspects of human nature.
Well, last word, final
word on the import
of any tentative conclusions
one might entertain
about human nature, one way
to assess their importance
is to observe how deeply they
enter into conceptions of right
and justice and actual
struggles that these conceptions
engendered.
So examples of the kind I
mentioned in the British case,
well, may be unusual, such
cases do arise quite commonly
in our lives.
That's essentially what
Hume was talking about.
More generally, every approach
to how human relations should
be arranged, whether it's
revolutionary, or reformist,
or committed to
stability, it is based
on some conception of human
nature, maybe tacit conception.
If it has any claim
to moral standing,
it's put forth with
at least tacit claim
that it's beneficial
to humans, meaning
because of their nature.
So for example, take Adam
Smith's harsh condemnation
of division of labor
and his insistence
that in any civilized society,
government must, in his words,
take pains to restrict it and
mitigate its harmful effects.
That conviction was based on an
empirical assumption, his words
that the man whose life
is spent performing
a few simple
operations will become
as stupid and ignorant as it's
possible for a human creature
to be, which is morally
impermissible, he argued,
because it violates fundamental
human rights grounded
in human nature.
Like other capacities,
human understanding
will not flourish
along its own course
without external triggering.
It's like in Smith's
words, without the occasion
to exercise the understanding,
and therefore, people
must have the occasion,
or it's an infringement
on their fundamental right.
That's a pretty standard
enlightenment doctrine.
Another one of the founders of
classical liberalism, Wilhelm
von Humboldt, argued that humans
are born to inquire and create
an infringement on the
natural, this natural right,
is unacceptable.
An infringement on that
right would prevent them
from exercising those intrinsic
capacities to the fullest
extent possible.
Hence, illegitimate.
Accordingly, as he put it, if an
artisan produces beautiful work
on command, we may admire
what he does, but we
will despise what he is, a
tool in the hands of others
and not a free human being
acting in voluntary association
with other free people.
The strong popular resistance
to the modern industrial system
was inspired by
similar conceptions.
When the system was taking
shape right around here
in eastern Massachusetts
150 years ago,
there was a lively
independent press
run by artisans and shop
workers, many of them
young women from nearby farms.
And it makes interesting
reading today.
They weren't borrowing from
any intellectual tradition.
They were expressing themselves.
These are mostly quotes.
The contributors
denounced what they
called the new spirit of the
age, gain wealth forgetting
all but self.
They condemn the loss of
dignity and independence
of Rights and Freedoms,
the degradation and loss
of self-respect, the decline of
culture, skill, and attainment,
as they were subjected
to what they called
wage slavery, forced
to sell themselves,
not what they produced, becoming
menials and humble subjects
of despots, reduced to
a state of servitude
that was not very different
from chattel slavery
of the southern plantations.
So they felt-- these
are quotes, actually.
And those ideas were not at
all uncommon at the time.
They were upheld in large
part by the Republican Party,
for example.
And they were of profound
concern to the masters,
huge capital and
intellectual resources
have gone into the
effort to drive them out
of people's minds,
very consciously.
This goes back to the early days
of the Industrial Revolution.
And dramatically, so
in the past century,
when one of the
major industries,
modern industries, public
relations industry,
was created, essentially
for that purpose.
In the words of some
of its leading figures
back in the 1920s,
it was created
to regiment the
public mind every bit
as much as an army regiments
the body of its soldiers
to impose a
philosophy of futility
and a focus on the
superficial things of life,
like fashionable consumption,
and to prevent people
from harming themselves
by taking charge
of their own affairs, just
as a responsible parent
would prevent a child from
running into a busy street.
All of this was justified
explicitly as good for people,
reflecting human
nature, and reflecting
the fundamental inadequacies
of the less intelligent,
including their
unique malleability.
And that's a crucial
assumption that
removes any moral barriers
rooted in human nature that
might be conceived
in different ways as,
indeed, it was conceived
by the subjects
of these benign manipulations.
Conflicts over human nature,
what are in our tradition
called inalienable
rights, they lie
at the heart of the slow
evolution of the human rights
culture over the
past few centuries.
An optimist could hold,
maybe realistically,
that history reveals a deepening
appreciation for human rights
as well as considerable
broadening of their range,
including in very recent years.
This is not without reversals,
sometimes sharp reversals,
but I think the general
tendency is detectable and real.
Inquiry into these
slow changes--
so, for example, the
debates over slavery,
for example, which
were rational debates.
Inquiry into these
slow changes suggest
that what may have happened
could have been attainment
of a clearer insight into
our own basic values rooted
in our nature.
These are issues that are
very much alive today.
For example, conflicts over
ratification of human rights
conventions, or to take
a current case very sharp
and divide in the
world today over
unilateral military
intervention for allegedly
humanitarian reasons.
I think a case can be made that
these are the appropriate terms
for framing the issues, to
some extent, comprehending
the history.
And it's at least imaginable,
although hardly imminent,
that scientific inquiry
might offer some guidelines
for approaching the extremely
significant issues that
arise, perhaps, offering
some answers to questions
that, as far as I can see, we
can only speculate about today.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
KEYSER: All right.
So now we're open for questions.
And if you have a question,
please, maybe the best
thing to do would be to
stand up and speak loudly,
so that the entire
audience can hear.
And you can address
it to the panel
or to individuals on the panel.
So we have about 20 minutes.
Claude.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question of Dr. Pinker,
but also the panel at large.
Your principles derived from
the Judeo-Christian theories
around me.
The entire model seems to
be relative to-- derived
from western culture.
On the parallels
in eastern culture,
can we substitute
Buddhism, for example,
Zoroastrianism,
Shintoism, and come up
with a similar set
of conclusions?
Oh, I'm done.
PINKER: The question is,
are there parallel theories
of human nature implicit in
the other major religious
traditions?
There certainly are.
I'm very far from
an expert on them.
But there is a wonderful book
called 10 Theories of Human
Nature by Leslie Stevenson, and
I forget the co-authors name,
of which, I think, 6
of them might belong
to different religious
traditions, Judeo-Christian,
Buddhist, Confucianist,
and so on, and then
Marxism, psychoanalytic
approach, ethological approach,
and so on.
But certainly, I
think every, indeed,
every religion does have a
theory of human nature embedded
in it.
AUDIENCE: Are they similar?
PINKER: Oh, there are some--
the best I can say is
that there are certainly
some similarities.
And the major proselytizing
religions, I think,
all have some notion of
choice and a moral sense
as part of human nature.
They're not deterministic
in the literal sense
because that would obviate the
need for a religion to tell you
what to do, tell you how
to exercise that choice.
But that's the main one.
But, again, I'm not enough
of an expert to really answer
that question intelligently.
CHOMSKY: If I can add a--
a good way to test the question
you're raising, one way to test
it is to have a look
at the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights.
Human rights are founded in
some conception of human nature.
And the history of the
Universal Declaration,
the 1948 Declaration
reveals that there
was very active contribution
from a wide variety of--
in fact, any very broad variety
of religious and cultural
traditions.
It was not a reflection
of Western values,
as sometimes said.
And they managed to reach
a considerable consensus
on a fairly detailed
accounting of human rights.
Not that anyone lives
up to the principles
but at least formulating
them as desiderata.
PINKER: One other thing.
Certainly, whenever there is an
articulation of what morality
consists of, you
get some version
of a kind of golden
rule ethics that
is the interchangeability
of the interests and rights
of different individuals.
I can't expect you to
submit to something that I
would refuse to submit to.
And that, indeed,
seems to have been
rediscovered in a great
many moral traditions.
The philosopher Peter Singer in
his book The Expanding Circle
argues that, in
fact, moral systems,
the world over, tend to be quite
alike, except for one parameter
of variation, almost like
the linguistic parameters
that Noam introduced.
And that is, what is the size
of the circle of entities
that you count as persons and
whose interests you regard as
interchangeable with one's own?
And, in fact, a very simple,
but not oversimplified
theory of the kind of moral
progress that Noam alluded to
is that the circle has
gotten bigger and bigger,
that it used to include
basically your own village
and then it expanded
to include the tribe
and both sexes and all races
and eventually all of humankind.
And many current
moral debates consist
of whether we should
expand the circle further
to include, say, warm blooded
animals, or animals in general,
or species, should
species be treated
like individuals with a
right to exist and respect
for their interests?
But the psychology of how
we evaluate the moral claim
seems to be remarkably
parallel modulo
this parameter of how
big the circle is.
PUTNAM: I guess, as a
professional philosopher,
I want to be annoying
to Steve, and say, I
think the talk of a
Judeo-Christian theory
of human nature, I mean,
nothing comes to mind.
For example, he meant,
well, there is a theory
that humans have a moral sense.
I'm trying to think whether the
whole Talmud, which certainly
was the lead Jewish,
body of Jewish thought
until the beginning
of the 19th century,
contains a single expression I
would translate as moral sense.
I don't think it does.
There is nothing in Aristotle--
moral sense theory is
an 18th century theory,
a 17th, 18th century theory.
It plays no role in Aquinas.
If you move to the Greeks,
the big change, I think--
you can't translate moral
sense into Aristotle's Greek,
because moral didn't
have the same mean--
moral is from Latin,
and it's from mores,
and that's a translation
of the Greek ethics.
But ethics did not--
but the ethical sense
is not a term that
would make the slightest
sense to Aristotle.
Where I think there is an
interesting shift in the west--
well, this is to
the east as well--
for Aristotle, this
ethics had to do both
with how we should
behave to others.
And I agree with Steve--
with the last thing
he said, is right.
The universality of something,
like a golden rule principle,
does seem to be very strong.
But for Aristotle, the
tremendously important question
was, what human
flourishing consists in,
a question which is of great
importance to you and Chomsky.
Eudaimonia is sometimes
translates as happiness.
And Aristotle is really
human flourishing.
And one effect of the
religions coming--
I think one bad effect-- and I
say this as a practicing Jew--
but one bad effect of
the rise of the victory
of Christianity and
Judaism and so on
is to suppress that
question somewhat,
because it was supposed
to be obvious, what
human flourishing consists in.
And so make ethics almost
entirely synonymous
with the question of what
are your duties to others
to the point where it's
often said the notion of--
Bentham said the notion of a
duty to yourself is incoherent.
And I think we need
to keep in mind that--
well, anyway, I don't think
any simple stereotype will
summarize the ethical thinking
of either the West or the East.
PINKER: The criticism
is completely valid.
To put it mildly, talking about
the Judeo-Christian tradition,
embraces a great many
figures, ideas, and so on,
so it's bound to be
a simplification.
I meant it really in
just the minimal sense
that there's a presumption
that we have an ability
to measure courses of action
against some ethical standard,
some coloring.
And that's probably the most
that you could get away with.
PUTNAM: Yeah, but the
most common term for that
was simply reason,
or even common sense.
[? Savara ?] in the Talmud
is just the general term
for common sense.
KEYSER: Yes.
Andrew, Levinson, and Christy
Keenan have microphones,
so let's use those.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My question is for
the entire panel,
but, I guess,
mainly, because I'm
most familiar with
Professor Chomsky's work.
In the same vein of
the last question,
I'm just interested
in each of you,
what do you use as primary
and secondary sources
as far as history
sources, current event
sources, and the organizations
that possibly publish
these and put these out?
And the reason is,
is because, I guess,
with kind of a new
wealth of information,
it's kind of hard to kind
of mull through this.
I'm 25, so the
internet's been around
for a good part of my
lifetime and just inundated
with a lot of neat information.
But how much of it is useful
is a different question.
So I would like to know
what you subscribe to
and where you get your first--
the information where--
to analyze what's
going on in the
world day to day.
I mean, it's--
CHOMSKY: Well, there's never--
I mean, at least
in recent history,
for those of us who are
reasonably privileged
and don't have to spend
the entire day trying
to feed our children
and so on, there's never
been a shortage of information.
You're just flooded
with information.
And the same is true in the
sciences and everywhere else.
So like a good physicist is not
someone who knows most data.
In fact, any person--
probably-- correlation's
probably the opposite.
I won't mention any names, but
there is one old friend of mine
who was a Nobel Prize
winning scientist, who
once said that when he
teaches his courses,
he makes up the facts
the way they ought to be.
And then he sort of
challenges the students
to try to check and
see if he got it right.
Have them find out.
And the point that
he was trying to make
is that the information in
itself is just a nuisance.
I mean, like the data,
the phenomena of life,
or a nuisance, you have to
know what questions to ask.
PUTNAM: This is from
a man who carries
more information in his head.
CHOMSKY: No.
You have to ask the
right questions.
And there's no, if I may
borrow the word, algorithm,
for doing that.
So it really wouldn't
help to list--
I mean, you could look
at footnotes and things
we've written, and that'll
tell you what we looked at,
but you have to find for
yourself what kind of questions
you want answered.
And search for answers
to those questions.
And nobody can tell you
where you'll find them.
PINKER: I'll put
in a plug for my--
if I had to name my single
favorite source of information
for just recreational
information trolling on the web
would be the pair of sites
called Arts and Letters
Daily and SciTechDaily,
AlDaily.com, SciTechDaily.com,
both run by a wonderful
man named Dennis Dutton who
lives in New Zealand.
And it's basically
pointers to the three most
interesting stories
everyday sampled
from maybe 100 different
journals, magazines, reviews,
and so on.
So those would be my two picks.
PUTNAM: I can improve
on Noam's answer.
If you bring a good
question to almost any data,
you'll get a great
deal more out of it.
KEYSER: If, however, you
go to Google on the net
and put in Chomsky,
you'll get 113,000 hits.
Yes.
Hang on.
Christie will bring
you a microphone.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question for Steven Pinker,
or anybody that
wants to answer that.
But you touched on in your
talk, and what I want to know
is how far do you think
the tools of science
can be used to
explain human nature?
Are there areas of the arts
and humanities that are just
out of reach of
scientific tools,
like cognitive neuroscience,
or behavioral, genetics?
And I would just
say that I recently
heard a talk by E. O.
Wilson who says that there
are biophilic patterns
in art from Picasso
and other expressionist
paintings that
are universal in nature.
PINKER: Well, I think that
the study of cognitive science
could certainly illuminate
the arts and humanities.
The plots of the
world's great fiction
are fairly restricted number
of themes of human conflict
and human interest.
Media, like painting and
music, clearly exploit
properties of the visual
system and the auditory system
and there's a lot of interesting
work by people like, say,
Elaine Scarry at Harvard on
how cognitive science can help
illuminate the fictional
narratives by the use
of visual imagery, for example.
Obviously, the study of
literature, arts, humanities
isn't going to be taken
over by cognitive science
and evolutionary
psychology, but simply
because a few principles
can only get you so far,
but I think there's a
great deal of insight
to be gained by linking them.
I'll just mention
one other example,
which is the work of Jay
Keyser using elements
of linguistic theory,
the theory of phonology
to illuminate
contemporary poetry.
Very interesting work
that shows how fruitful it
can be to bring
traditional poetics,
or traditional humanities,
arts, and arts in general
together with cognitive science.
PUTNAM: I think, to ask
whether there are problems
in the humanities and the arts
and so on that are out of reach
is the wrong way of
thinking about it.
It's as if all the problems
are scientific problems,
it assumes that all the problems
and the line we have to--
the divide we have to make
is in scientific problems
that are tractable and
scientific problems
that are untractable.
Now, obviously, there are within
science both tractable and
intractable problems,
but there are also
questions, which are
not scientific at all.
Their vocabularies, which are--
their vocabularies,
whose purpose,
whose reason for existence
isn't to formulate causal laws.
You mentioned that the
term reductionism is vague,
as Steve Pinker
pointed out, but there
is one kind of reductions,
which is certainly
a fallacy, the
logician Frege, who
is the founder of modern
symbolic logic, referred
to psychologism, because
he was thinking of one very
narrow sort of reductionism.
In his day, psychology
really meant association
of ideas, and
especially association
of mental images, which
is a very limited kind
of psychology.
But the point he
was making, which
is that the question of
whether an inference is valid,
when something is
really a proof, which
is why I use this example,
is a wholly different kind
of question from the empirical
question of what causal
mechanisms of
association, or whatever,
went on in the
mind or brain when
the person gave that proof.
And to confuse
those two questions
is to miss, what I call,
the normativity of logic.
I mean, I am a pluralist.
I think we have many--
we need many, many
different language games.
And no one of our language games
can describe all of reality.
KEYSER: Am I missing anybody?
Oh, good.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I'd like to ask somewhat
of an obvious question that
relates to the subject
of this gathering,
specifically about
the point of having
a humanities department in a
technical institute like MIT.
And I'd wonder if you could
talk a little bit about what
the role of it is and
whether over the years
there is a sense of
prejudice against humanists
versus scientists.
CHOMSKY: Well, I guess I'm the
one with the longest experience
here, so let's talk about that.
When I got here, it
was in the mid 1950s,
and MIT was basically
an engineering school.
Even the basic
science departments
were pretty much
service departments.
I mean, they had super
scientists in them,
but their role in the institute
was service departments.
Actually, I think
I introduced one
of the first undergraduate
philosophy courses
in general, philosophy
and analytic philosophy
back in 1955.
And I guess it's not
telling a tale out of school
if I say some of the things
that students who were then
undergraduates asked me.
So, for example, I remember
the first philosophy course
I introduced that students,
undergraduates came
to ask what the course
was going to be about
and should they take it.
And I'll never forget one
student who came and asked me
whether this would be the
kind of course that would
help him meet Radcliffe girls.
Radcliffe was then
separate from Harvard.
The point was that he had
to go to these parties
with all these Harvard kids who
were hot shots and new word,
things like, names, at least,
like Kant and Freud and so on.
And we just kind of
helped him compete.
Well, that wasn't so far
from the way things were.
It changed a lot.
It changed a lot for
a lot of reasons.
I mean, one of the reasons
it changed, I think,
is because of-- a major
reason, was Sputnik.
I've always had a
sneaking suspicion
that Sputnik was actually
sent up by US scientists.
They all knew that it
didn't mean a thing,
but they exploited
it fantastically
to get an enormous amount
of money and support
for science education
and enriching
the scientific
institutions and so on.
And one very visible
consequence of this
was that MIT changed from
an engineering school
to a science based university.
And as it became a
science based university,
there was an increasing
and a quite natural demand
for enriching the
humanities courses.
And it sort of grew
naturally out of that.
So it was certainly since--
in fact, the whole
service function
of many of the
departments changed.
They became core departments,
not service departments,
including humanities.
Linguistics was the same.
I'll just tell you my
own personal story.
When I got here in
the 1950s, actually,
I was in a laboratory,
but I had to sort of pay
my way in the humanities
department, then
the modern languages department.
And the way we did
that was by teaching
cram courses for
graduate students,
mostly like civil
engineers and others.
In those days, there was a
kind of crazy requirement
that to get your PhD,
you had to fake your way
through language exams.
And I stress, fake your way,
because it was understood
by everyone that you
were going to be trained
to learn how to fake your
way through a particular exam
and they were never going to
open an article in that field
again.
And that was done
for a long time.
Well, that's what the
language and linguistics
was at the time.
And it changed.
It changed in a
very natural way,
I think, as the
university shifted
towards becoming a
science based university
with a demand and a need for
rich surrounding departments
that exist on their
own initiative.
KEYSER: I think
that's a terrific way
to end the session.
And I hope you'll all
join me in thanking
the panel for a terrific
beginning to this celebration.
[APPLAUSE]